would you date like an influencer like a
Jenna Jenna
or Kylie Jenna Kylie Jenner Oh I thought
he was going to say yes now I'm getting
a different no no
no I think he's going to say yes final
answer honestly and I'm I'm probably
going to get dragged for this but I feel
like I'm I try to be very upfront and
honest I would date her
opportunistically I told you I told you
okay this was more of like a request
I feel myself getting grossed out
already wait what does that mean
huh sit on that for a
second do you do you know what that me I
don't know what that means I don't know
what that means it's when you like the
inside
e ew why would you tell me
that that was like the weird and I'm I
had to look it up I'm like I don't even
know what this person's at and she
did what up guys welcome to the just
Carly things YouTube channel and welcome
to my reaction series before we start
get yourself a women [__] about t-shirt
today they are delivered and shipped
this week so make sure you get your
T-shirt the link is in the comments um
so today I'm reacting to this is why you
should not date a boss bab of me if a
girl makes more money than me although
at this point in my life that's a very
small proportion that make more than I
do uh but uh in the past I've did women
who make more money than me I don't it
doesn't bother me but there can be some
corresponding personality traits that
can come with Hyper successful women for
example I mean to be successful in
business you need to be there's a
certain degree of cutthroat like for
example someone who's who's uh yeah I've
heard that from guys um with like
high-end lawyers in like Corporate
America like those women I've heard
they're [__] than normal women and
I've heard that they're also they come
with like masculine traits tempor
mentally whether you're a man or a woman
is going to probably lean towards being
more disagreeable than like the average
population in order to be a lawyer you
you have to be yeah I've heard guys say
that do not date lawyers I've heard that
argumentation so I mean the lawyer is
going to [__] run circles around you
when it comes to like you know if you
ever get into a [__] argument with
your boyfriend girlfriend they're a
lawyer like watch out not necessarily
but um they're going to [__] like lay
out okay here's the rules here's the
laws and [__] um but uh that's not
always the case there are some women who
are hyper successful that are still
feminine um I think it I think the thing
with women who make a lot of money I
think it more so falls on women who do
make a lot of money not finding men who
who are not on their level attractive
because like for example take a woman
who's a lawyer or take a woman who's
like a successful businesswoman she's
probably not going to look at a guy who
as we said earlier works at like a fast
food restaurant and yeah that's
generally true View him as a suit it's
like um the I talked to this
evolutionary psychologist and he said
that it's like high earning tall women
have it the harder I was like no dang
it mate when he said tall is actually
harder for women because out of all the
couples he said out of 100 couples only
two exist where the woman's taller than
the man soar that's the toughest one
whereas like a guy who's a guy who's an
attorney will gladly date like a hot
Barista or like attractive you know she
could be a college student or whatever
so yo Andy donated
$100 Burke and Mandy you guys said you
drove together any of collabs in the
works also the girl with flowers on her
shirt looks like Sloan from Ferris bu
who's I've never seen that Sloan um
where were we we were talking about a
woman's income yeah I mean here uh Jake
would you would you date H she's not
great but she makes a lot
Kylie Jenner no no no way she's like
she's like all up in that la like
influen a Vibe and it's just it's not
she's a Kardashian I find I find humble
I feel like Brian would date her I'm
getting a different vibe from Brian
humble girl is very you DM Jenna Orga
that was a joke I never DM her oh you
didn't DM her it was a
joke and if I did she would have applaud
yeah confidence we like the confidence
but yeah think as guys like I mean I a
lot of the women I date I'd say uh you
know in recent history they've probably
been around my age they've been
professionals I like girls in stem I
like girls who've you like dokey girls
yeah I kind of like nerdy girls so like
they tend to make good money like
they'll uh you know anyways in any case
um but I would also date like a girl are
you saying he's not dating the the corn
star from the other episode no we're not
no who's 21 who's works at chick FL
would you date like an influencer like a
Jenner Jenna
or Kylie Jenner Kylie Jenner Oh I
thought he was going to say yes now I'm
getting a different no I think he's
gonna say no I would no no no I think
he's gonna say yes final answer honestly
and I'm I'm probably going to get
dragged for this but I feel like I'm I
try to be very upfront and honest I
would date her
opportunistically I told you I told you
guys there is going to be a plethora of
guys that look at the market and think
this is way easier this is way easier
doing the whole working thing all these
women are making so much money let's
let's live life on easy mode granted she
she is couple months and then you yeah I
was going to say she's attractive but
like it a lot of it's really plastic and
I don't like plastic like I don't like
fake lips I don't like fake tits um
question no offense to anybody here who
may have plastic surgery what question
what's up do you think she she would
date you oh
no do you see the realisticness that men
are just so much more honest he's like
yeah no not a chance in hell I mean
never say never right but uh uh
opportunistically I mean she could get
some but if you dated her
opportunistically then are you doing
what Jonah's ex-girlfriend's doing and
being an opportunist and I I mean women
date opportunistically all the time I
mean I think half of women have admitted
to going on a date for free dinner
there's a difference well but here's the
thing I think there's a difference
between like exposing someone
vindictively for revenge and like dating
someone for their status women do that
[__] all theing time like women will
date a guy who's like and look men will
date a a woman because she's insanely
[__] hot I just think it happens to
be the case that women value status and
wealth more than uh more than men do it
SS unusual cuz it's coming from a guy
I'm just like yeah I'm being extremely
blunt no most people are not going to
admit yeah I would date someone who's
like extremely wealthy and famous for
opportunistic reasons look I mean also
the the the lip fillers and the I don't
know plus sing I re that be incredibly
boring to be around am I toxic I don't
know I'm being honest at least I'm being
honest you're being I appreciate that so
I'll feel that but I don't know there's
I don't know question says would Jake
and Brian date a female prison guard if
they were locked up for life I mean what
other choice do you have if you're in
prison it's like Beggars can't be
choosers you know what I mean would you
that she if she came came knocking what
would you date her who who's her Kylie
Jenner Kylie Jenner is she are you B no
have we established that yeah I like I I
also like no respectfully
respectfully is it opportunistically or
is it like well you might is we're
talking about like you yeah you might
just be playing the game like Brian I
someone I'm more like
the maybe my framing is wrong doesn't
everybody date someone from an
opportunistic like it's either this
person is really physically attractive
therefore I want to date them like it
starts the catalyst is like like a what
gets your attention Okay so I'm not a
total scumbag okay good I'm glad I'm
glad everybody agrees that some some
people yes could be that and a lot like
a majority yeah maybe but like there is
guys that date women yeah this is going
to be a trend and I noticed this already
I see the gym Bros with like the lawyers
or the gym Bros with like the corporate
women I see it I see the trend let me
know in the comments if you guys can
think of any like um careers that tend
to go with each other I've noticed
career women tend to get like Fitness
guys even like high earning women
influencers they'll get them a fitness
man opportunistically like that of model
that ended up killing her boyfriend
Actually I don't even know what her
boyfriend did but he was like in good
shape like there we don't take into
account like all the guys that have
dated like famous I think women tend to
like socially calibrate that sort of
thing a lot more though like they tend
to really analyze things socially like
social groups and like who's where and
then date people because of future
prospects and that sort of thing whereas
guys are much more like sort of we see
something and we're like okay yeah she's
cool boom boom boom right let's do this
as an F Creator I've definitely bumped
into some guys uh I don't know if you
guys can relate with me but some guys
who have definitely been like hey come
be my sugar mama like it's it's hard
it's it's but but You'
also you'd also you'd also bump into
guys who send you photos of their penis
and say laugh at it you know 1% and I
laugh at it every single time
exactly guys are guys are into weird
[__] so like is is like you can't really
take that exception and make it the rule
yeah yeah um it is an exception he's
right but you're going to see it's going
to come more Tinder swindler types more
really just the guys that realize they
can monetize their look I mean we have a
Society right that's discriminating
against men for jobs giving the high
earning jobs to the women even though a
lot of them don't really deserve it in
HR and like Tech and stuff I mean some
guys are just going to look at the
market and pick the easier thing you
know what's funny I saw a poll that had
over 20,000 polls like people that
responded and I I want to say was like
80% of men would want to stay home with
the kids if they could yeah and a lot of
times I think gynocentrism has really
made us think that it's only women that
want to stay home with the kids but you
know guy guys are going to look at the
market and say that is easier yes if
you're only going into a relationship
for someone to take care of you it's
like what where are you going to you
guys should it's 100 100 not 5050 you
should be able someone should yes say
can I ask a question Bri to to the girls
who do only fans what is some of the
weirdest requests you've ever had that
is a great question there's a what some
of the strangest things you've ever seen
I have one okay go for it someone asked
to like okay okay this was more of like
a request right that I feel myself
getting grossed out
already give aapse in real life like
prolapse them in real life wait what
does that mean
huh sit on that for a second do you do
you know what that me know that means
does public I don't know what that means
that means no explain it in the most
YouTube way possible prolapse they're
they're bum hole okay like it's one you
like the side is on the outside oh
what's the
next e why would you tell me that
e that was like the weird and I'm I had
to look it up I'm like I don't even know
what this person's and she did it e e e
e e no I didn't do oh she didn't do it
okay oh thank God I found out what it
was and I'm like I don't even know they
wanted you to do that online for them no
like like that was it was a request to
for a larger amount of money to do it in
that's disgusting that is I I I I
thought we were going to like watch him
School a chick that makes a lot of money
by this title and I just got scarred by
the end of that video I didn't need to
know that today didn't need to guys the
culture has gone so far left and it it
it makes me sad okay that I'm growing up
in a time where sex work public sex work
is getting normalized these are the new
influencers we even have a congresswoman
that are former strippers former former
of workers and we almost have like no
shame in this Society anymore this is
disgusting but you know let me know what
you guys think in the comments get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
in the description and make sure you
tweet at me with the hash ieem your
women shouldn't vote t-shirt like the
video on your way out and I'll talk to
you next time